[Music]
the eSport is giving like new
opportunity for the racing drivers
coming up for us it's very difficult
because we have a lot of financial
difficulty so even on the real racing we
have much less like testing days
comparing to all the drivers it is quite
expensive you know for all the weekend
take care of the expensive hotel so we
used to sleep on the car as well my dad
decided to give me a Playstation 2 and
you know to introduce me to the
motorsport many competitors down to this
one ego Frogger Igor Frogger is going to
finish this race in first place 21 races
six World Tour events of a true Series
champions of the world in 2019 and look
at him he knows if this is his race to
win first place for the Brazilian Igor
Fraga is one of f three's newest drivers
for those who don't follow open-wheel
racing f3 is a path to Formula One the
pinnacle of the sport for junior drivers
it's an opportunity to showcase their
talent to potential f1 and f2 teams and
in February Fraga got one step closer to
his dream by signing with f3 teams crews
racing system following that up days
later by winning the Toyota Racing
Series but when he wasn't racing on the
track Fraga was competing in esports
racing simulators
they go wrong
21 whose job kid Wow
frag has been racing all his life he got
his first taste at the age of three when
his father got a gran turismo in a
steering wheel I was introduced in the
Motorsports in a very young age at the
age of three I was already sitting on
the Gorka heading they bought me like a
steering wheel PlayStation 2 and then it
was when I started on like the simulator
back in the days was very very much
simple you know the technology were not
advanced but at least I was able to know
what is like throttle braking because
very important when you are putting your
kid to our go-karting now normally
sports games are nothing like the
real-world counterparts if you're bad at
basketball becoming the best at 2k
isn't gonna help you but racing Sims are
different well they can't reproduce the
movement of being in a real car they let
drivers practice on real tracks with
cars they would use in real competition
the high quality sim racing the guys
that playing things like race room and I
racing in particular now factor to those
guys those are so realistic the
simulations are so realistic in the game
that to be good in it you need to
understand everything there is about the
car which means you need to understand
it how to set up the car and then on top
of that track understanding how to take
two different speeds of which appear
which speed they learn all these things
in the game the reason that lando norris
max Verstappen
used the games to learn the tracks in
real life so well he continued to race
in real life fregley devoted his time
off the track to racing Sims and this
guy got really do it in first place and
second place that Brendan Lee and Evo in
the Mercedes and the
well he finished 18th in the inaugural
Formula One eSports Series Fraga
simracing prowess was on display the
following year at the FIA GT
Championship 2018 Nations Cup world
finals
[Applause]
[Music]
Fraga continued his success into 2019
starting the new year by becoming the
first McLaren shadow you sports champion
Braga is going to finish this race in
first place and iam your Egor you have
to be so happy with what you just ran
and look at him he knows it this is his
race to win first place for the
Brazilian that wind gave Fraga the
opportunity of a lifetime to hone his
driving skills at MacLaren's Technology
Center McLaren shadow project champion
Eagle Fraga he be over five hundred and
twenty five thousand competitors to be
crowned the season one Shadow Project
winner and can rightfully claim to be
one of simracing
elite talents he spent the following
year developing his skills both on and
off the track with the help of
MacLaren's driver development smarts and
Fraga capped off the year by winning the
2019 FIA GT manufacturer Series World
Finals sweat see what races six World
Tour event series champions of the world
in 2019 Toyota wait the manufacturer
series Monica but just because Fraga was
dominating in the eSports side of racing
doesn't mean that he stopped competing
in real life in fact he was doing better
than ever coming third at the 2019
regional European Championships while
still competing in esports I am very
happy you know to be able to put this
performance at today as well on the
track he's also now a part of the Red
Bull junior program for 2020 which is a
development system that gives
up-and-coming drivers the resources they
need to hone their skills
this development program has helped
produce some of the best drivers in
Formula One well you can't discount his
recent performances on the track frege's
eSports experience certainly helped in
getting him signed to f3 he showed the
world in other aspiring drivers that
there's another path to making it in
racing one that's not so expensive you
know on the real life it's I think you
know a lot of people know but it's a
very expensive sport so basically the
simulation you can do many laps you want
prepare yourself for the real racing as
well at the end of the day it's very
close to the real racing and you really
can can do the bridge between this to
ward you no thanks just I'm in eSports
Fraga gained notoriety and opportunities
like working with McLaren that he may
not have gotten otherwise
right now the eSport is giving like new
opportunity for the racing drivers
coming up like building a different way
to be to become a professional driver so
it's a very interesting and which I
having so much fun being part of Fraga
prove that racing Sims are more than
just games they can help turn dreams
into a reality in my career I helped
Billington visibility and also driving
skills to be able to achieve those type
of level you always have to really
challenging yourself that's high level
of competition it was like something
that I learn a lot this point it's like
much easier to start on because of the
course and everything you know you can
just buy it you don't have to have like
a place closer to you to get involved
you can be like a new way to discover
some talent thanks for watching if you
want more content like this hit the sub
button and ring that notification bell
for unique bite-sized videos you won't
find anywhere else hit up our Instagram
Twitter and Facebook pages
[Music]